gave it a magic me yeah this is your
magic mirror you totally got the short
end of the stick Evie we wanted to see
you using your powers in descendants
three instead mal and uma got all the
glory but they didn't realize how much
they benefited from your secret powers
you don't even need your magic mirror
anymore
your powers come from within and you use
them like the stylish boss that you are
we hope you stay close to mount when she
becomes queen of word on she's going to
need your special powers the Evil Queen
gave Evie a lot more than a flawless
complexion she also gave her some pretty
awesome powers but Evie has a secret
power that no one knows about except for
the core for of course watch until the
end to find out what it is
here are these powers explained Evie's
origins Evie's mom the Evil Queen is an
alchemist she cast spells using potions
Evie doesn't believe in using magic
spells but her alchemy mixing powers
make her excellent at combining fabrics
and accessories no wonder her fashion
business is thriving
Evie mentions in the novel's that she is
a witch but out of all of the villain
kids she seems to be the quickest to
adapt to the ways of word on that means
giving up her magical witchy powers to
live among the common subjects of the
kingdom in her own castle of course but
how did she manage without her powers we
believe she's been using her powers all
along without anyone realizing it we'll
get to that a little later
Yuma's powers fans were perturbed by the
fact that Emma and mal teamed up to use
their powers in d3 and left Evie's
powers out who may use the powers of her
mother
Ursula's seashell necklace you know the
one that stole Ariel's voice in the
Little Mermaid why did Emma get to use
her powers but not Evie can you imagine
how powerful Evie Mallon Ouma would have
been if they all combine their powers
Audrey
wouldn't have even stood a chance
against them but then again maybe Eevee
was partially responsible for Audrey's
defeat but more on that later
mouths powers we saw the full extent of
mouths powers in descendant three she
doesn't need her spell book anymore now
has shape-shifting abilities making it
possible for her to become a dragon but
she also has spell casting abilities
every time her eyes turned green her
powers are activated her mom is a
shape-shifting fairy dragon and her dad
is the god of the underworld that makes
mal half fairy and half God this means
that she is the most powerful person in
all of word on
it's no wonder mal can make up powerful
spells right there on the spot our
favorite was in night falls when she
cast the spell suit of armor strong and
true make this metal box to move did
anyone else love watching the Knights
dance like mal Ouma and Carlos magic
mirror it's established that Evie is a
witch but what's the story with her
magic mirrors Evie's mirror was a family
heirloom that was handed down to her by
the evil queen
so Evie must possess certain powers to
be able to use the mirror it's in her
blood
since Evie was born on the Isle where no
magic is allowed her mother never got
the chance to show her how it works but
Evie instinctively knew how to use her
powers to activate the mirror when she
was in auradon the power of fashion
we've already touched on this earlier
but it bears repeating Evie's fashion
powers are unparalleled in auradon and
on the Isle she created the fabulous
outfit mal wore for the cotillion she
definitely had a hand in mouth dragon
wing dress at the beginning of d3 and
you know she will conjure up all of her
magic to create the most epic wedding
gown ever for mal and Ben's wedding
it took Evie no time at all to build a
thriving fashion business with Doug's
help of course the power of love we all
know how powerful Evie is when it comes
to Friendship she's the only one who can
get through to mal when she's being
stubborn but did anyone else notice the
power of her love for Doug even before
she woke him with true love's kiss she
had him dancing around her while he was
totally asleep Edie's love saved the day
in more ways than one
doug is such a lucky guy Eevee's true
powers we've explored all of Evie's
abilities except for one it happens to
be the strongest out of all of her
powers have you ever noticed how Edie is
always able to cut through the drama and
get to the truth and the heart of the
matter
that's her true secret power Edie
possesses the ability to see the truth
in all situations she's the voice of
reason in d3s number nightfalls she can
always get through to mal and convince
her to do the right thing her powers of
perception have grown so strong she
doesn't even need her mirror anymore he
can see right into the heart of everyone
she meets she knows how to disarm them
and convince them to change their evil
ways you know what we should try an ice
breaker this is a power that she did not
learn from her mother this power is all
Evie's she doesn't need a mirror or
potions to make a difference she can do
it all on her own all while looking
fabulous
which one of Evie's powers is your
favorite and do you think she should
have showcased her abilities in
descendants three sound off in the
comments subscribe to the thing so you
never miss another video and be sure to
click that thumbs up button too
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]